- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is: Be Yourself.
Over to you, Whoopi Goldberg.
(explosion noise)
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- Well, my life is a
class if I was to say,
it probably teaches
that you can be yourself
and an individual if
you are comfortable with not everybody
liking you or how you think.
If you're comfortable with
going against the grain.
If you're comfortable
with people making fun
or saying really nasty stuff.
If you're comfortable with all of that,
then you can be yourself.
That's the price.
The price of being yourself is, you know,
other people's angst
about you being yourself.
- I think this is such
an important message
for entrepreneurs because
if you want to have success,
as an entrepreneur, in
life, but especially
as an entrepreneur, if
you want to have success
it has to come from you being you.
From you being willing to break the rules.
From you being willing
to express yourself.
From you being willing to fail publicly
and know that even the
fact that you were willing
to try and fail is an inspiration.
Use it as an inspiration
not just to yourself,
but to others around you.
And the people who are watching you,
and judging you and
throwing tomatoes at you
and saying you're not
good enough and saying
that was such a stupid
mistake and laughing at you.
(bright music)
You have to learn to ignore them.
Because if you just
constantly live your life
according to other people's judgments
and expectations of you,
then you're never going to have success.
You're living up to somebody's expectation
who's never done what you want to do!
Your family or friends or
people in your community
who are saying that you can't do this,
and you should be doing this,
you should go down this path
instead of doing, staying
here and going here,
you should be going down
this path according to them.
Well have they done what you want to do?
So you're living your life according
to what these people's judgments are?
You're never going to have success.
You're just going to be a
smaller version of them,
and chances are, they
haven't done much either.
So take the little that they've done
and be smaller because that's not you.
Congratulations, that's a happy life.
You can't just be a copy of somebody.
You can't shave your head,
wear a Believe hoodie,
you come on and do top ten videos
and expect them to do as well as mine.
You can't outdo Evan Carmichael.
You can't out-Evan Evan.
Just like I can't out-you you.
Don't copy me.
Go and do you.
Don't say yes because
somebody wants you to.
Say yes because it's meant for you.
The thing that I might
disagree with with Whoopi
is that to get to the comfort,
you need to go through discomfort.
It's like saying, don't be afraid.
It's going to work out, don't be afraid.
You're going to be afraid!
It's okay to be afraid!
It's okay to have fear
standing up to somebody.
It's okay to have fear putting
something out in the public
that you don't know is
going to work or not.
It's okay to be afraid.
It's not don't feel the fear,
it's feel the fear and do it anyway.
It's feel that fear that
people are putting on you
or you're putting on yourself
that this may not work,
that this expression of myself,
I'm pouring my heart out here
and people may not accept it.
And people may laugh at it.
People say that it's stupid
and it'll never work.
Pouring it out there anyway.
Because you know that
it has to be released.
Because you need to know.
Here's a quick personal example.
When I first started
doing these videos here,
I did it at Toronto Dance
Salsa and we're in a mall,
and there's people walking by constantly
and there's people who
look in every now and then
and see what's happening in here.
What's this guy doing in
the dance studio with lights
and a book behind him talking
and yelling into a camera,
what's he doing?
And at the start, that was something
that I was sensitive about.
And in between, it's even worse.
Like in between the
clips, I have my head...
I have my headphones on, and I'm dancing.
I'm doing this.
I'm walking around the studio, doing this.
You see?
There's somebody watching me right now.
That's how I, this is what I'm doing.
Walking the studio.
Dancing.
Thinking about what I'm going to say next.
And people are walking by.
And I would let that hold me back.
I would let their judgments
make me play small,
so instead of doing my
dancing I'm doing this,
I'm doing it smaller.
Why am I letting myself play smaller
because of some stranger's
expectations of me?
Why are you letting yourself play smaller
because of strangers' expectations of you?
You will only have success by being you,
by letting the thing that is different
about you come through.
And at the start, since
you're nurturing it,
since you're starting it off,
it's the start of anything,
you're going to suck at it.
It's not going to be the best expression.
It's not going to have a
fantastic result, chances are.
And so don't expect it.
Expect it to fail at
the start, that's okay.
You keep going.
If you keep practicing, I promise you,
you'll get to the point
where it's comfortable.
Where you don't care.
Where you can let go
of their expectations.
Just like working out, your
muscles will get stronger.
But when you first start doing it,
you need to recognize that
it's going to be scary,
that it's going to be uncomfortable,
and it's through that obstacle,
it's through the discomfort
that you get the comfort.
Comfort is on the other
side of the discomfort.
The answer isn't crouch back
and be a small version of yourself.
'Cause if you stay here, you're always
going to stay here, your whole life.
And you have to break through
to get to what you can be.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what was the biggest thing
that you had to break through,
the biggest discomfort that you had
to break through to be yourself?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Vamsi Polimetla.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book, "Your One Word."
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.